my name is Chuck I am a co-founder along
with my brother Gary and vaynermedia and
we're a social media agency with a focus
on social strategy and community
management you know I've always known
that context and I didn't know how to
express it was the whole game right for
example you have a feeling towards me
right now that is different than you
have towards AJ because we engage
together last year so we created context
right and now you have a different
feeling towards AJ because he answered a
question for you and the ability for us
to scale that in the social web really
matters while everybody thinks that all
this engagement and our kids are not
social anymore they're always on
computers if that thesis was right then
we weren't social when we all talked on
the phone all day
I mean it's silliness emotion breaks
through and and and real live feelings
breakthrough products they go through
those wires through the cloud and they
touch this they touch this they touch a
lot of things and I believe there's an
enormous opportunity there's a war to
win the most context with a consumer or
an end user and that's kind of what I
think about the thing that drives me to
do what I'm doing at the present moment
is that I have a goal that may be
different Gary's and Gary always talks
about buying the New York Jets and
that's definitely on my list of goals -
and there'd be nothing better for him to
buy it or for me to buy it for us to buy
it together or for him to buy the Jets
and for me to buy the Knicks that'd be
amazing but the goal that really drives
me more so than that day-to-day is the
quest for me just to be happy at every
moment and to be in control at every
moment that's why I think
entrepreneurship is so amazing if done
right it gives you the ability to
control your actions and to make
yourself happy when you want to make
yourself happy the the fear that I have
and when you know when graduate in
college the fear that I did have was
that I wouldn't be in control of my own
happiness that I would be subject to
somebody else's thoughts opinions and
guidance and you know I think being an
entrepreneur is great in a lot of ways I
think that's the major factor for me so
my my hope for
next big thing is that Gary and I will
do something together that'll make us
happy and that'll continue down that
path